Speaker 1: Carrie Lake lost the 2022 Arizona
gubernatorial election.
She lost.
What I mean by that is her opponent, Katie
Hobbs, got more votes.
And as a result, Katie Hobbs will be the governor.
I think six year olds would understand this.
Who got more votes while Katie Hobbs got more
votes?
Oh, so who won?
Katie Hobbs won.
So what does that mean?
It means Katie Hobbs becomes the governor,
not Carrie Leek.
Because Carrie Blake lost because Carrie Flake
received fewer votes.
It sounds so simple.
And yet Carrie Lake simply will not go away.
Carrie Lake won't simply say it's over.
Carrie Lake delivering another one of these
highly filtered.
I've never seen a blur filter the way that
Carrie Lake's videos have.
She put out a video updating her supporters
about her fight.
Now understand what it means that she is fighting
this.
This small detail is so important.
She's fighting for an election where she lost
because her opponent received more votes.
It's that simple.
And yet here she is.
Question Is she grifting or is she actually
fighting?
I don't know.
Let's see if we can figure it out.
Speaker 2: Arizona.
It's Carrie Lake, and I wanted to update you
on what's happening in our fight against Arizona's
sham elections and those who run them.
For starters, I want you to know that I am
firmly in this fight with you.
Maricopa County just couldn't wait to certify
their botched election, the botched election
where half of Election Day voting centers
were inoperable.
Speaker 1: That is a lie.
Half of the voting centers were not in our.
There were a few machines that were malfunctioning
for a portion of Election Day.
We've talked about it already.
Speaker 2: The botched election where Election
Day printers caused mayhem across the county,
the botched election where Arizonans were
expected to wait in line two, three, four,
even 5 hours simply to exercise their sacred
right to vote.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, in other places,
other counties are overwhelmingly democratic
areas, making people have to wait for hours
to vote.
Is a strategy from the right.
They closed down polling places and early
voting in overwhelmingly or places, parts
of the states that favor Democrats in order
to create long voting lines, which they say
is fine.
But here lines are indicative of suppressing
the Republican vote.
Think about that.
Speaker 2: Arizonans were told to throw their
vote into a draw where it might ultimately
end up in a plastic bin or a trash bag.
Maricopa County, where it took two weeks to
count, is the poster child for broken botched
elections.
But if you bring up any of these issues, you
are labeled an election denier.
Speaker 1: Well, when you're lying, you are
called a liar conspiracy theorist.
Speaker 2: They don't want us talking about
our shady elections under any circumstances.
They shut us down and made us fear exercising
our freedom of speech.
And they canceled anyone who questioned past
elections.
Because of that, many Americans did not speak
out and nothing was done to shore up elections.
And now we are paying the price again.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, nothing was done
to shore up elections in the immediate aftermath
of 2016 when real vulnerabilities were identified,
including the vulnerability of our elections
broadly to foreign influence.
Many, particularly Democrats, tried to actually
do something about it.
Republicans didn't want to hear it.
Mitch McConnell didn't want to hear it.
So when we identified a real problem, we did
try to fix it.
They didn't want to fix it because they like
the results.
Now that they've identified imaginary problems,
they say nobody else wants to fix it because
it's part of the way that the left is stealing
elections.
It is quite literally backwards from reality.
Speaker 2: Arizona, America, if we do not
stand up and speak up right now about the
most dishonest elections in the history of
Arizona, I truly fear for our future.
Our sacred vote is supposed to be the great
equalizer of the people.
And right now, our vote has been trampled
upon.
We must work hard right now to save it.
This is our last chance.
Those of you who are speaking out about what
happened on November eight, those who testified
before the corrupt board of Supervisors.
Speaker 1: That includes the people who said
that there was treason, the people who said
it was demonic, that that's who she's talking
about.
We looked at clips of that yesterday.
Speaker 2: Thank you and God bless each of
you.
Speaker 1: The people she is thanking, many
of them are insane.
Speaker 2: I am with you.
Here's what I'm busy working on.
I'm working with a team, a patriotic, talented
lawyers on a legal case to challenge the botched
elections.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, many of those patriotic
talent, talented lawyers who got involved
in 2020, many of them were disbarred.
Speaker 2: My team and I realize how important
this case is and what is at stake.
We will file this case in accordance with
Arizona state law, and you'll want to stay
tuned for this one.
Trust me.
So many have expressed concern about Maricopa
County certification.
Speaker 1: I think you get it.
This reeks of desperation and it reeks of
grift.
Trump thought in quotes Fort, which was really
fundraised money, right?
The last big grift.
Although maybe the last big grift is him now
running for president again.
Trump fought for two years and he got nothing.
Are they really going to fall for this all
over again?
So let's go through the facts just so we're
clear on them.
Maricopa County officials said to numerous
media outlets, including to USA Today, no
extra ballots were counted at any voting sites
in the county.
There has been no evidence that people who
wanted to vote were unable to vote.
They've seen no evidence that the ballot drop
boxes were insecure.
And they have also not been contacted by many
of the individuals that Kerry Lake and others
claim are, quote, working on this issue.
The county has processes to ensure legal ballots
are counted one time, not zero times, and
also not two times that the drop boxes were
secure.
The tabulators.
Which.
A few of them briefly malfunctioned on Election
Day, were repaired.
Even the RNC, which initially filed a lawsuit
over that, withdrew the lawsuit because it
was demonstrated to their satisfaction that
everything was on the up and up.
This is all made up.
And at this point, I genuinely don't know.
Is this number one a way for Carrie Lake to
keep raising money?
I don't know the answer to that.
Is this number two, Carrie Lake, being a true
believer in any of the nonsense that she's
saying, including that she's fighting for
the election?
Again, the election's over.
We're almost a month beyond the election.
She lost her opponent one or two.
And I'm increasingly of the mindset that this
is the most likely explanation.
Or is this Carrie Lake auditioning to be Trump's
VP?
Is that really what this is about?
That much like and I know I mentioned this
yesterday, many Trump supporters who maybe
didn't literally believe Trump won in 2020
said it because it was how you pledged allegiance
to the team.
It's not the Pledge of Allegiance to the flag.
It's the Pledge of Allegiance to Trump.
And the way you pledge allegiance is by saying
Trump won.
Is Carrie Lake doing the same thing and wanting
to position herself to be Trump's 2024 VP
by saying the exact same stuff Trump said
about 2020 and quite frankly, the exact same
stuff Trump has been saying about Carrie Lake's
own election, which we will get to a little
bit later.
Let me know what you think.
And remember, if you're watching our clips
and you are not yet subscribed on YouTube,
please subscribe.
This is May Jeb Bush please clap moment.
Please subscribe.
Last month, over 3 million people watched
our clips but didn't subscribe.
We could get to 2 million subscribers overnight
on YouTube if the people already watching
our clips hit that subscribe button, help
us out.
We're going to take a quick break and be right
back.
The David Pakman Show is a community funded
program.
We depend on your support.
We do what we do every day, including all
three YouTube channels, the audio podcast,
the radio show, the TV show, as well as now
the new white paper, including the one about
building arguments without burning bridges.
Available for free at David Pakman dot com
slash guide.
All of that is funded by the membership program
you can sign up at join Packman dot com.
I believe the normal prices are an incredible
value for the hours and hours and hours of
content we produce every month in audio, visual
and now written form.
But you can also use a coupon code to save
even more.
That code is 24 starts now.
24 starts now at join Packman dot com.
And of course you get the award winning bonus
show with your membership.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Now, I admit all of the awards
the bonus show has won are our awards we give
out.
It's sort of like when Trump wanted to give
himself the Congressional Medal of Freedom,
but nonetheless they are awards and you can
sign up at join Packman dot com.